can i talk to you about roger penrose
sure
you've talked to roger on the portal
but also in between the lines and
offline just
everything you've said about roger
penrose for people who don't know
he just recently a few days ago won the
uh
2020 share the 2020 uh
nobel prize for physics but
it's clear to me that he had like a deep
personal
impact on you a connection with you
in terms of both your love of
mathematics just the way you see the
world
like the this is the eddie van halen
conversation this is clearly somebody
who's profound in your worldview
can you talk about roger can you talk
about what it means
that he won this highest of prizes just
in general let's celebrate the man yeah
okay
so first of all there are two other
people who won this prize i'm sorry i
just didn't happen to know who they were
before they won
roger is a very it is not roger in
particular
but the class from which roger comes
that is so important
so i would put roger in the class of
feynman einstein derock
yang um
you put whitten in there i know
i mean whitten's a special case but
whidden is weirdly the reverse of the
roger penrose story right because witten
is the first
physicist to win a mathematical fields
medal the highest honor in mathematics
penrose is in some sense a mathematician
who's now won the nobel prize
so it's a perfect sort of a couplet yeah
um roger's class
means everything to me that's the
highest
achievement of the human mind i'd
probably throw bach
in with feynman and dirac and company
right
i think that he was so inventive
it was very frustrating to watch this
career it's a little bit frustrating to
watch
feynman's career feynman
was so good
and had he been born slightly different
at a slightly different time
i believe his claim on physics
would be far greater
i feel like penrose in some sense came
up a very difficult path
because you see einstein effectively
solved most of the most important
problems in general relativity right at
the beginning
as a result the children of einstein are
impoverished
because there wasn't as much to pick off
of the trees
and sell at the market whereas bore
didn't
and plonk didn't do nearly as good of a
job with quantum theory so there's lots
to do in quantum theory
i think that roger affected me
personally
um by a diagram that i
saw in a paper of hermann gluck at the
university of pennsylvania
it was the first picture i'd ever seen
of the hop vibrations sketched
and that you know weirdly i brought that
to the rogan program
in order to sort of convey the wonder it
was recapitulating my
own journey i think i probably saw that
at
like age 16 or something it just flipped
my mind
roger is incredibly visual he's
incredibly geometric he's incredibly
suey generous he just does his own thing
he's got lots of bets none of them had
really come
through the way you would hope and
i think they stretched the rules to be
blunt about it uh to give him the prize
yeah
i do you you said this thing on twitter
which is beautiful
that every once in a while comes a human
being that
gives uh value to the prize versus the
prize giving value to the human
two different kinds of prizes the reason
that we care about the nobel prize
isn't because of alfred nobel it's
because it came along at the right time
to reward um
einstein derock schrodinger
feynman most of the most of the people
who should have won
one most of the awards
are not good in the sense that they
don't really follow
the prize is used to rewrite history
that's its problem
so it's you should have a love-hate
relationship with it because on the one
hand it does
focus the world on what really matters
and on the other hand it distorts what
really matters and both of those
functions
take place simultaneously in this case i
think that they violated their own rules
slightly
so it wasn't really clearly a case of a
prediction and a discovery in the
typical fashion
but they like we better give this award
to somebody of that highest caliber
to make sure that the prize is fully
funded with prestige going forward
that's that's sort of my weird
speculative guess as to what happened
and so roger's getting on in years and
the person should be alive
so they i think they meant the rules and
i think they couldn't have bent it for a
better person and i hope they will not
bend the rules
out of weakness but out of strength in
the future
it would be great to get madame wu
and emmy nerder a posthumous prize along
with doug prasher
george sudarshan
and george zweig as well as ernst
stickleberg
nobel prizes there have been some
terrible omissions
on the first two being females who
revolutionized our view of the world
and i've take a very dim view of people
pushing for prizes for people from
ethnic groups or
genders or whatever in order to make it
plural and inclusive
if it's not following the work and i
feel very clear that in a few cases we
know there was a real problem with the
nobel committee because
we have stunning accomplishments and try
to get through a day as a physicist
without
nerder's theorem and try to imagine the
universe without madame wu's discovery
that left and right don't appear to be
symmetric
i mean these are terrible omissions and
they're a huge blot
on science for not being more
inclusive when it matters yeah so just
like you said the nobel prize is
plagued by omissions as much as and
distortions and dilutions for example
derock and schroedinger were i believe
given the
the prize in the same year there's no
reason that those two people needed to
dilute each other
the same thing with you know dyson was
an omission
tomonaga probably got included in part
because
we had an opportunity to show that
something had happened on both sides of
the pacific after the war
but i don't think we needed to dilute um
weinberg
or feynman or schwinger it just makes me
it makes me somewhat sick all of these
people are such important giants and it
has to do with the field i think
not wanting to create luminaries and
superstars who could have defended the
field from budget cuts
and worldly pressures so i think it's
really important
that we have absolute superstars because
we produce superstars
we acknowledge them we don't dilute them
and that we bend the rules to make sure
that the prize stays funded with the
prestige
that comes from giving it to the roger
penrose's
albert einsteins and paul derocks of the
world
you